- [Instructor] Jerry was reading
about a study that
looked at the connection
between smartphone usage
and happiness based on data
from approximately 5,000
randomly selected teenagers.
The study found that on average
the teens who spent
more time on smartphones
were significantly less happy
than those who spent
less time on smartphones.
Jerry concluded that spending more time
on smartphones makes teens less happy.
All right this is interesting.
So what I want you to do is think
about whether Jerry is making
a valid conclusion or not.
And why or why don't you think
he's making a valid conclusion?
All right now let's work on this together.
This is really important to understand
because you will see things like this
in the popular media all the time
that try to establish a causality
when there might not be causality.
Or at least where the study might
not be able to show causality.
So right now Jerry is
saying he's concluding
that smartphone usage, smartphone usage
makes teens less happy, so he's
assuming there's a causal connection.
Smartphone usage causes
teens to be less happy.
Less happy, can he actually
make that conclusion
from this study based
on how it was designed?
Well the first thing to ask ourselves
is is this an experimental study
that is designed to establish causality
or is it an observational study
where we really can just
say there's an association
but we really can't make a
statement about causality?
Well in experimental
study he would have had
to have a control group
and then a treatment group
sometimes called a experimental group.
So I'll say that's control group,
that's the treatment or
the experimental group.
And then you randomly assign folks
to one of those two groups and then
you would make that treatment group
use a cell phone more and
see if they are less happy.
That's not what happened here.
What happened here was
an observational study.
In this study we are
looking at two variables.
So you have your smartphone usage
and then you have the teen happiness.
And they took these 5,000
randomly selected teenagers
and they figured out
their smartphone usage
and their happiness, maybe
with a survey of some kind.
And then you could plot those data points.
You would have 5,000 data points.
So this data point right over here
would be a very happy teenager
that doesn't use a smartphone much.
This would be a not so happy teenager
that uses a smartphone a lot.
And so you would plot those data points
and there might be a teenager
who's unhappy and doesn't use a smartphone
or one that is happy and
that uses a smartphone a lot.
But you can see there's a trend,
there's an association that in general
the teenagers who use the smartphones more
seem to be less happy and the teenagers
who use the smartphones
less seem to be more happy.
But it's important to realize
that the causality could
go the other way around.
Maybe less happy teenagers
use their smartphones more
and maybe more happy teenagers
don't find a need to use a smartphone.
Or there could be some variable
that's not even being
observed in this study
that has a causal relationship
with both of these.
So there could be some other variable
that might cause someone to be less happy
and use their smartphone more.
So in an observational
study, you can really
just say there is an association.
You wouldn't be able to say
that there is causality.
So Jerry is not making a valid conclusion,
it's an observational study, we've only
established an association not causality.